liberal Insanity getting downright scary
almost squatters
terrorizing a Portland neighborhood by
setting fires in a vacant property
residents blame liberal policies that
have allowed squatters to take over
homes despite several eviction notices
one couple forces stock up by fire
extinguishers okay
and say it's a worse than a war zone
and I felt safer walking downtown in
Saigon when I was over in Vietnam than I
do here in Portland I think this is
happening because uh the people of
Portland Oregon have voted for policies
that promote things like
fires next to my home people that are
living there aren't being moved out so I
have hope that things are being done
it's just is it going to get to the
point where my actually home catches on
fire
yeah that's not very good for property
values there Harold
yeah I don't these kinds of stories
continue to obviously they proliferate
and I don't understand what local
governments are doing I don't understand
that policy I understand at some level
at some level a small level I disagree
with some of the cashless Bell stuff as
it related to non-violent stuff but I'm
in disagreement with that now this
policy here allowing squatters uh to
squat in someone's home they don't own
or live there I don't understand this
policy especially when you see what's
happening and to kind of fear people are
grip with in Portland I've been to
Portland in the last few months it's a
beautiful it's a great City but there's
certainly a level of fear that that
people in that City have and someone
that was just visiting for a night or
two that I even had as I was downtown in
Portland and it's a great City I hope
they're able to get back Devil's
Advocate squatters rights
judge squatters rights that's it no no
that's my decision Waters right no you
don't have squatters rights you know
unless it's kind of like adverse
possession has to be open notorious
continuous exclusive Ocea and I learned
that in law school got me there okay but
here here's the bottom line yeah it is
no this is up to the locals okay when
they say this is happening because the
people of Portland have voted for
policies that promote things like fires
next to my home he said no it's
happening because they're not making
arrests that's called arson that is a B
felony in Most states get your mayor to
make them please the chief of police
enforce the laws and if your mayor won't
have the chief of police enforce the law
then make a citizens arrest and drag his
ass to the police department that's two
A's how tragic is that is the guy's
blasting this little tiny personal fire
extinguisher what he needs is a hose he
does need a hose I think we all need a
hose is homeless squatters I mean what
Hypocrites right pick a side weirdos
look
Harold you guys have nailed it there's
nothing positive coming from our
response to homelessness there's no
Silver Lining or bright spot to how
we're dealing with this we've decided to
create artificial rights to people who
have no idea why we're even doing that
right they don't know why of course you
have a right to live on the street of
course you have a right to camp and be
harmful to yourself and others we're
doing that Meanwhile we're taking rights
from everybody who actually tries to
live decent lives by pretending to give
these people rights we're actually
taking away their rights as human beings
we're letting them live like animals
starting fires on the street animals
can't even do that they don't have
opposable thumbs but that's why we're so
powerless because we're powerless in
these local situations because we
believe that we're the bad guy if we if
we violate the rights of people who are
daily violating their own rights and
other people's rights why do we accept a
small segment of society to subject all
of us to this bizarre weird delusion
it's happening everywhere I hate to say
it but Greg makes a good point he makes
a pretty good point this is true I think
that this what's happening in Portland
should be a warning to cities all across
America even small towns so make sure
that at your city council this isn't
happening don't allow this because it's
a little camel's nose Under the Tent and
then the next thing you know the camel's
homeless under a tent or something I
guess that's filthy but I also don't
understand why there it hasn't been this
person
I don't know why there hasn't been a
reporter that pulls together everything
that says okay they used it pandemic as
an excuse but then but then what is
inflation also a problem and where do
you connect that to
um are the big Tech layoffs a problem
and what do you connect that to when
when has that been happening when is
when who's going to pull together all of
those threads to write a Nifty little
story and how about the rise of China
economically geopolitically didn't that
happen after we were shut down we could
go on all day let's do that let's just
blow the brakes
Sorry Brad we're going to midnight I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now